critical time to have this debate the
resolution on the floor the March 2003
war in Iraq was necessary and just our
first speaker will be Christopher
Hitchens he will speak
he will speak for 15 minutes George
Galloway will then have 15 minutes to
respond we'll follow the same order for
the next two rounds one of ten minutes
and then five minutes and then we'll
have a 35 minute discussion and follow
up with five minute closing remarks when
the order will be reversed George
Galloway is with the respect party MP
for Bethnal Green and bow in East London
he recently he recently testified before
the Senate permanent Subcommittee on
investigations hearing on May 17
responding to charges related to iraq
soil for food program he's the author of
a new book published by the new press
called mr. Galloway goes to Washington
Christopher Hitchens is a widely
published polemicist and frequent radio
and TV commentator contributing editor
to Vanity Fair author of a long short
war why Orwell matters the trial of
Henry Kissinger and many other books
including two published by nation books
which he'll be signing tonight love
poverty and war and blood class and
Empire we'll begin first with the
opening statement of Christopher
Hitchens
but thank you very much Remi you can
take it out of my time but I would
propose that we begin with a moment of
silence for the 160 people who were
sadistically murdered in Baghdad this
morning as they went to their places of
work or stayed in their places of abode
and as they hope to register for the
upcoming elections I hope I can get an
agreement for a moment of respect for
them
very good and I thought those comments
were also very worth the hearing I'm
very grateful to the organizers for
making this possible I considered a
great distinction to stand on the podium
at Baruch College named for the Bernard
Baruch who the first in 1946 proposed
that weapons of mass destruction be
placed under international inspection
and control I'm grateful to the audience
also for giving me the chance to revisit
my mr. Ben Trotsky is Jase dishing out a
leaflet in steaming heat on the street
outside made me feel and look I hope
much younger and we're also of course on
this side of the house here to share
with mr. Galloway the ambition that his
views and his record be much better
known than they are and most of your
hope will have the leaf that the details
this and there's a huge heir until
there's we were watching or joining us
from other audiences can go to Hitchens
web.com and download the whole lot and I
hope they will and share it an
impression I think ladies and gentlemen
has been allowed to form and it perhaps
even to coagulate and to congeal that it
is only those of us who support the
regime change the revolutionary change
in Iraq who have any explaining to do
I think that that assumption needs to be
counted from the very beginning if you
examine the record of the so-called
anti-war movement in this country and
imagine what would have happened had its
counsel being listened to
over the last 15 and more years you
would have a world in which the
following would be the case Saddam
Hussein would be the owner and occupier
of Kuwait he would have succeeded in the
annexation not merely the invasion but
the abolition of an Arab and Muslim
states there was a member of the Arab
League and of the United Nations and
with these resources as we now know
because he lost that war he was
attempting to acquit himself with the
most terrifying Arsenal that it was
possible for him to lay his hands on
that's one consequence of anti-war
politics that's what would
have happen isn't meanwhile slobodan
milosevic would have made Bosnia part of
a greater Serbia and Kosovo would have
been ethnically cleansed and also
annexed the Taliban would be still in
power in Afghanistan if the anti-war
moment have been listened to and
al-qaeda would still be their guests and
Saddam Hussein with his crime family
would still be privately holding
ownership over a terrorized people in a
state that's been most aptly described
as a concentration camp above-ground at
a mass grave underneath it now if I had
that record politically I would be
extremely modest I wouldn't be demanding
explanations from those of us who said
it's about time that we stopped this
continual capitulation to dictatorship
to racism to aggression and to
totalitarian ideology that we will not
allow to be repeated in Iraq the
failures in Rwanda and in Bosnia and in
Afghanistan and elsewhere and we take
pride in having taken that position and
we take pride in our Iraqi and Kurdish
friends who are conducting this struggle
on our behalves I should say what did it
mean to accept this responsibility we
knew it was a way she won and we knew it
was a dangerous one I've argued I will
argue that the war was both just and
necessary I think what can separate
perhaps the two concepts Iraq had lost
its sovereignty as far as a state can do
under international law there are four
conditions under which a state may be
deemed or said to have sacrificed its
sovereignty these are if it participates
in regular aggressions against
neighboring states or occupations of
their territory if it's violates all the
little letter and spirit of the terms of
the non peripheral excuse me the
non-proliferation treaty and in other
words fools around from mysteriously
with the illegal acquisition of weapons
of mass destruction third if it should
violate the Genocide Convention the
signatories to which are obliged without
further notice to act either to prevent
or to punish genocide and fourth if he
plays host to international gangsters
nihilists terrorists and
artists Iraq met all these four
conditions repeatedly and would have
demonstrated its willingness to repeat
them on many occasions its sovereignty
was at an end it was under international
sanctions it was a ward of the
international community its people were
being starved in order to build palaces
for their psychopathic dictator and it
was furthermore imploding as a state and
as a society the divide and rule policy
of the Baath Party had led to appalling
ethnic and confessional hatreds within
the country an imploding state would
have made these worse and you know who
would have invaded them turkey would
have invaded to try and take Kurdistan
Iran would have invaded to support its
extremists Khomeini I'd proxies and
Saudi Arabia would have intervened in
order to do the same favor for the Sunni
and Wahhabist
and Salafist extremists as a matter of
fact all these three Florin
interventions are taking place at
present all those three powers are
trying to meddle in Iraq but we're
fortunate as are the Iraqi people that
there is a coalition to hold the ring
and to prevent it from becoming another
Rwanda or another Congo another vortex
of violence and cruelty and
destabilization and war and this I think
again is the point to take pride in it
was the only responsible course I'm
willing at any point to take questions
and I'm sure I shall be invited to about
my own criticisms of and misgivings
about differences with those who
conducted and conduct this policy but
but on this main on these main points it
seems to me that there's very little
room for debate what are the thank you
now we we know when we make no secret of
the extraordinary difficulties that have
attended this this I think very noble
and risky and worthwhile Enterprise all
of you will know all of you will have
seen some of the abysmal consequences of
this but you have I think the
responsibility of imagining what the
alternative would be I am simply going
to say what I think the positive reasons
are excuse me the positive consequences
are and I hope someone will be showing
me the time Amy just so I don't trespass
on my own argument or the patience of
the comrades who's gonna be showing me
the time yeah okay will you let me know
when I've got three minutes say positive
results ladies and gentlemen brothers
and sisters a man who planned and
ordered and supervised and took delight
in the genocide and torture and
aggression and the occupation of two
neighboring states and the massacres of
their people is in jail now and we'll
follow slobodan milosevic and our gusto
Pinochet into the dock quite soon I know
there are some people here who don't
take delight in this but I will say that
I do that it's a long-overdue justice
a long overdue act of justice and mercy
a constitution the federal democratic
constitution is being debated now as we
speak with the printing of five million
copies of aboriginal document debated on
six television channels six and perhaps
as many as a hundred newspapers in a
country where three years ago it was
death not just for you but for your
family to possess a satellite dish or to
attempt to distribute a leaflet death
for you and your family and not a quick
one either does anyone not agree that
this is a night and day difference I
invite them to say if they turn the
largest stateless minority in the Middle
East the people of Kurdistan in other
words who have suffered many years of
oppression and exile and and occupation
in Syria in Iraq in Iran and in Lebanon
and in Turkey have begun to scramble so
just say to their feet to assume
something like their full height as a
people even before the intervention they
were producing an autonomy a democracy a
self-determination of their own in the
provinces of northern Iraq which when I
saw them last were were a landscape of
of desolation and depravity you could
still smell the poison gas you could
still smell the mass graves the ruined
cities the burned hillsides that the
women who had chemical burns that still
burn after years out of this the Kurds
have begun to build and help other
Iraqis blow when they could have been
chauvinistic they could have been
xenophobia they could have said enough
with with Iran with we're through with
it we're leaving instead accepted their
international responsibilities president
Talabani
it seems to me as a president of whom
any country in the region could be proud
and not just by the sort of comparisons
one could make this is an extraordinary
unarguable unambiguous gain the
disarmament of Libya of capitulation of
Colonel Gaddafi his abandonment of
pervert arson with mass weapons of mass
destruction and the walking back of the
evidence that he gave us because we all
have it now thank you sir
in um in Oak Ridge Tennessee which I
think is the right place for it all
analysis was able to disclose to us that
the Providence of much of this illegal
weaponry was the AQ Khan Network in
Pakistan a kind of Walmart for WMD nukes
are us without line stretching all the
way from North Korea to the Iraqi n
voice who in knotch 2003 as the
coalition was preparing to intervene
were negotiating in Damascus with the
end voice of Kim Jong Il to buy North
Korean missiles off the shelf and people
say Iraq and WMD can't be mentioned in
the same breath now not everything about
this could be attributed to the
intervention but it's noticeable I think
that Colonel Gaddafi did not when he
wanted to capitulate go to mr. Kofi
Annan for example all that great
statesman mr. jacques chirac a man so
corrupt as is said of mr. Dalembert I
think in sentimental education so
corrupt you would willingly have paid
for the pleasure of selling himself nor
did gerhard schröder the rump figure of
what was once a proud german so he drops
you know he came to mr. Blair and so mr.
Bush and says I'm out of this game now
and you can analyze everything I've got
that's not nothing ladies and gentlemen
and it's a step towards disarmament and
non-proliferation into the bargain and
then the spread no less important of the
Democratic impulse within the region not
only is this being spread by the vector
of the Kurdish people in their
revolution because as you will will you
will be readily able to find if you
haven't read over it already they've
been demonstrations in come easily the
Kurdish main city in northern Syria
among the oppressed Kurds who suffer
under the ossified theocracy of Iran and
of course in Turkey as well to pick up
the message that yes liberation is at
hand these demonstrations broke out on
the day the president Talabani was sworn
in as president of Iran there's an
unmistakable connection between them we
who have been friends of the Kurds are
very
proud of their achievement we intend to
stand by them no matter what
I will add that the the moral leader of
the Egyptian democracy movement the man
who has begun to break open the argument
in Egypt and who suffered a long period
of imprisonment during this time and was
written to by Nelson Mandela as Egypt's
equivalent has told me and for quotation
that in his opinion this new mood in the
in the region would be unthinkable if it
was not for the removal of the single
worst tyrant who was present there
that's not nothing as in point of
testimony that's from deep within the
bowels of the Egyptian prison system the
man who is the moral hero of their
democracy really he says and I agree
with him and he's echoed by Anwar
Ibrahim as far away as Malaysia who was
the the Malay equivalent and by the
leader of the Socialist Party of Lebanon
mr. Jim Blatt have all stated publicly
that this for them is the beginning of
the end the fall of the wall as they put
it this I think is also something to
take pride in now I could have said this
in front of any audience and against any
antagonist but in my last two minutes I
will have to say that I believe it is a
disgrace but a member of the British
House of Commons should go before the
United States Senate subcommittee and
not testify but declined to testify and
to insult all those de Troyes from
asking questions with the most vile and
cheap guttersnipe abuse I think that's a
disgrace
that's not coming that's not coming out
of my time if you knew how you looked
and sounded comrades when you do that
well you the cameras can take care of it
that's not coming out of my time it is
not a just a disgrace it is a crime that
mr. Gaddafi has profited from the theft
of money from the Iraqi oil-for-food
program has told continuous lies about
his profiteering from it and the foul
associates that he made at a time when
Iraqi children were dying and 11 billion
from this program 11 billion went to the
murderer and criminal and sadist and
fanatic Saddam Hussein to hurricane
anyone who's a business partner of this
regime show their face in a city like
this and not content with it not content
with it the man searched for a
tyrannical fatherland never ends the
Soviet Union's let him down Albania is
gone the Red Army's out of Afghanistan
and Czechoslovakia
Saddam has been overthrown and his
criminal connections with him have been
exposed but long to the next on the 30th
of July in Damascus in Syria appearing
I've given it all to you in a piece of
paper in front of mr. Assad whose Jeth
squads are cutting down the leaders of
democracy in Lebanon as this is going on
to tell the Syrian people they're
fortunate to have such a leader
the slobbering dopher who they got
because he's the son of the slobbering
tired okay before him
socialist principle can actuall speak in
this way is beyond me and I hope ladies
and gentlemen far beyond you and far
beneath your contempt thank you
George George Galloway your response
well chair
ladies and gentlemen slobbering was the
note that mr. Hitchens chose to end on
I'm not sure that was wise bring it on
but I want to begin by praising mr.
Hitchens in Dundee my home city at the
annual delegate meeting of the National
Union of Journalists 25 years ago the
same
mr. Hitchens made a speech in which he
praised me and the City Council for what
he described as its brave act of
twinning the city of Dundee with the
Palestinian city of Nablus he said no no
no must have been so much that it was I
didn't interrupt you so perhaps you're
not slobber over my remarks someone else
you see it was very important mr.
hitchens support for the Palestinian
people and it was not easy in 1980 only
a few years before the Palestinian
resistance had seized the Israeli
Olympic Games team in Munich and had
committed what most people in the world
described as an act of mass terrorism
mr. Hitchens courageous stand with
groups like the Popular Front for the
Liberation of Palestine the hijackers of
many an aircraft the carrying out of
many a military operation was very
significant because it was very real
equally I want to thank mr. Hitchens for
the brave stand that he made against the
war on Iraq in 1991 I want to I want to
say and I've never had the chance to
thank him for this one of the magic
moments of that great era was
Christopher Hitchens on television with
the gun nut Charlton Heston when Heston
was fulminating desperate to get in
there desperate to attack Hitchens told
him to keep his wig on and then he asked
him magically to name four countries
with a border with the country he was so
keen to invade and heston of course
good name none that was important
because it was very difficult to oppose
the war against Iraq in 1991 after all
it was ruled by some day called Saddam
Hussein it was governed by the Baath
Party who continued to govern it
thereafter it was only three years since
those chemical weapons that mr. Hitchens
could still smell when he was last there
had been launched against the Kurdish
people whom he will never leave alone
only three years before Halabja had
taken place and of course perhaps most
significantly of all it was difficult to
oppose that attack on Iraq in 1991
because Iraq had invaded and abolished
to quote him a few minutes ago a member
state of the Arab League of the United
Nations a Muslim Arab country
notwithstanding all of these things
mr. Hitchens bravely fanatically you may
say stood against the idea of President
George Bush invading era in 1991 what
you are what you have witnessed since is
something unique in natural history the
first ever metamorphosis from a
butterfly back into a slug
I mentioned I mentioned Slug
purposefully because the one thing a
slug does leave behind it is a trail of
slime no I was brought up by my father
on the principle never to wrestle with a
chimney-sweep
because whatever you do you can't come
out clean but you mr. hitchens are no
chimney sweep
that's not coal dust in which you are
covered you are covered in the stuff you
like to smear on to others not just me
with your gob deleon leaflets full of
selective quotation half-truth miss
truth and downright untruth and the
comments you made in your last two
minutes of this speech but people much
more gentle than me people like Cindy
Sheehan
whom you described whom you described as
a sub sister as a flake as a la Russia a
woman who gave the life of her son for
the war that you have come here to glory
in people like mr. Hitchens are ready to
fight to the last drop of other people's
blood
Hitchens makes much and I know that he
will in his next segment so I shall to
coin a phrase content of the nature and
character of those resisting the foreign
invasion and occupation in Iraq I spoke
last night in Boston in a hall where
many of the leaders of the great
American Revolution stood and spoke my
favorite member of the British
Parliament has a statue it's the first
one you meet as you walk in st. Stephens
entry it is a statue of Charles James
Fox he was expelled twice from
Parliament for supporting the American
Revolution and supporting the French
Revolution now some might say Fox was
wrong
supporting the anti-colonial struggle of
the American people after all some might
say better be careful what you wish for
Charlie maybe one day the independent
free country you're supporting the birth
of will be ruled by crazed
fundamentalists like Pat Robertson and
George W Bush and Dick Cheney
and Michael a scroll
they might have said be careful charlie
if this country becomes free it might
one day not even be able to pick up the
dead bodies in one of its most important
cities a week after they've lend their
such as the malevolence and incompetence
of the government which will rule it but
Fox would have said no Fox would have
said no he would have said the American
people have a right to be free who they
choose to rule them is a matter for them
let them make their mistakes let them
have their own politics my country has
no right to occupy them any further of
Irish background myself when the Irish
people rose in 1916 for their freedom to
strike one of the first decisive blows
against the british empire on which the
Sun never set because God would never
trust the English in the dark when the
Irish people rose the hitchens of those
days in Bloomsbury in the salons
denounced the Irish rebels as priests
ridden bug trotting Celtic Gaelic
obscurantists to whom they would never
issue from Bloomsbury a certificate of
approval but the only certificate of
approval that mattered was the one
issued by the Irish people not the
Liberals in London who refused to
endorse it my point is this for us in
the United States and the United Kingdom
there is only one big question mr. Bush
actually framed it for us are you with
the foreign occupation of Iraq or are
you with the right of the Iraqi people
to be free and to resist the foreign
armies who are violently invaded them
and that's why that's why that she she
demagoguery by Hitchens at the beginning
of this debate got there is herbal
response that it did from this audience
because he wants you to have he wants
you to make a minute silence for the 145
today but he can't bring himself to
mention the massacre Intel offer over
the last four days in Iraq he doesn't
want to know about the massacre in
Fallujah when the American armed forces
destroy the city and massacred thousands
of people now this debate as Amy Goodman
said is taking place at a very important
time on a very important subject this
war in which he glories although I wish
how I wish upon a dinner and pick up a
gun and go and fight himself how I wish
how I wish to see that sight this war in
which he glories has cost the lives
according to those well-known Saddam
East fronts The Lancet and Johns Hopkins
University well in excess of a hundred
thousand people's lives and hundreds of
thousands more have been maimed and
wounded and it was all for a pack of
lies the world no weapons of mass
destruction
the world's no link between Iraq and al
Qaeda there was no link between Iraq and
the atrocities on the 9th of September
on the 9/11 here in the United States
there was no welcome for the foreign
armies that invaded Iraq Hedren said
they would be greeted by flowers but
there are 2,000 young American boys
lying in the ground now testimony to the
fact that they were welcomed by
something else and thousands and
thousands more wounded maimed many of
them in wheelchairs
for the rest of their lives testament to
the folly of Hitchens and Bush and
Cheney and the rest of the neocon gang
that dragged your country into this
disaster
International the International legal
and political system has been defaced
and disfigured the world has been made a
more dangerous place not just for us but
for our children and their children for
generations to come
the world has been made a more dangerous
place
Hitchens asked us to believe the
hundreds of thousands of Western
soldiers invading a Muslim country would
make less Islamist fundamentalism he
asked us to believe that devastating
Iraq and making a Yugoslavia on top of
the world's biggest oil field would make
the world a safer and more stable place
there is scarcely a sentient being in
the land who any longer believes that
the war on Iraq was either necessary or
just or a good idea
you may very well ask why so many people
wanted to come in here and watch and
listen to two British guys debating in
the United States of America about a war
far away I think the reason is this our
two countries are the biggest rogue
states in the world today
it is therefore it is therefore vitally
important that those who oppose the
crimes of our governments on both sides
of the Atlantic linked hands linked arms
stand shoulder to shoulder until we've
rid the world of George W Bush and
Anthony Blair once and for all thank you
very much
christopher hitchens ten minutes well I
think it's I can say that's a sort of a
pleasure to be by mr. Galloway under any
of my identities I've never made a
speech to the journalists conference in
Dundee for example I don't know who does
mr. Galloway's research though I think I
couldn't give my Eamonn McCann remember
him
I remember Eamonn McCann very well by
the way if he gives me the opportunity
to say that I've been a lifelong
supporter of the reunification of
Ireland and with Edward Sayid in the
early years of the Intifada as early as
86 published a book which you can still
get from new left books versa called
blaming the victims about the struggle
for for the full establishment of
Palestinian rights and yes it's true
that I was an opponent of the last car
for I don't know anyone thought that to
make such a point was the point against
me I daresay I might not have been
invited here in this this battle of the
Titans if if it wasn't tolerably well
known that I think I was probably
mistaken on that occasion if you can
assimilate a point as simple as simple
as that ladies and gentlemen which I
just say you can for I shan't insult you
now if you'll have to notice something
about what mr. Galloway just said in the
read the rhetorical I won't say trick I
would say squalid maneuver that
underlies it so hear him speak you would
think would you not that he was a
pacifist that he defines himself as
anti-war now how can this be said in
good conscience by someone who has just
standing by the side of the dictator of
Syria on the 30th of July referred to
the 150 for heroic operations conducted
in Iraq by the so called resistance or
resistance that's run as we know by a
senior bin Laden mist and by many of the
former secret police of the Baathist
regime
how can someone say and say their
anti-war they care about casualties that
they praised 150 for operations a day
145 ask you
145 he's coming down a bit
some of those operations were the
blowing up by military-grade explosives
of the headquarters of the United
Nations in Baghdad a few months after
the intervention as it was being tented
by Sergio de Mello one of the great
international civil servants of our time
who was fresh from ami knows more about
this than I would fresh from his role in
a very belated supervision of the
independence of East Timor from
Indonesia and the holding of free
election in East Timor and the jihadists
who murdered him put out a communique
saying we have today put an end to the
life of this disgusting man because he
freed Timor from Muslim holy land in
Indonesia these people are not pacifists
ladies and gentlemen nor are they
anti-imperialists if you haven't noticed
they call for the restoration of a lost
Empire the Caliphate and the imposition
of Sharia law on all non-believers
within its borders
that's not pacifism that's not answer
imperialism and to praise the people who
do this
- Sully the name of Charles James Fox
ladies and gentlemen with such a spoiled
with such a swirl enterprise of
brigandage and conquest is truly
revolting
it's almost as funny as Michael Moore
saying that the caveat resistance in
Iraq is for him the same as the
Minutemen of the American Revolution
there comes a point and I think it's
come by now where what people say is
self discrediting requires no more
comment from me some of this is funny ok
so it simply shows that the people on
the other side of this house are not
serious the cheap laugh or the easy joke
will do for them of course it's funny
that the author s of The Vagina
Monologues puts mr. Galloway on the
campaign trail with Jane Fonda who can't
laugh at that I know I know a number of
women who can't wait people who used to
know mr. Galloway to hear a woman talk
back to him in any way at all but the
seriousness of it can't be concealed now
among the people killed by these heroic
operations in Iraq some of them run from
Syria and paid for by the human
toothbrush and slobbering dopher Assad
mr. Galloway's new pal among the victims
of these of these operations was
specialist Casey Casey Sheehan who was
trying to clean up the festering slum of
what had once been called Saddam City
and was now known to us as Sava city
where the water supply is coming back on
it's taking a while because people keep
blowing it up but it's coming back on
now I will put a simple moral
proposition to you and see if I phrased
it aright is it not rather revolting to
appear in Damascus by the side of
outside and to praise the people who
killed Casey Sheehan and then to come to
America and appeal to the emotions of
his mother
I say sincerely I didn't think it could
get as low as that and yes I did
criticize the luckless mrs. Sheehan
because she had made a very unfortunate
political statement suggesting that she
agreed with mr. bin Laden that George
Bush was the murderer of her son which
is not the Sun the Sun you exculpate the
murderer Yuet still paid the killers
right there they didn't kill him shame
on you shame on you for saving her now
she had made an unfortunate statement
which I called her on if she denied
having made it which is false claim and
she said that someone else had magically
inserted into her email which has
claimed equally found to be false all of
these claims ladies and gentlemen can be
found to be false by moment's checking
if you really believe the crazed
fabrication fabrication of the figures
of a hundred thousand deaths in Iraq and
if you think that only people who died
in Iraq excuse me but the only deaths
caused in Iraq are by coalition forces
if you're willing to believe any or all
of that you can simply go to my
colleague Fred Kaplan's space on Slade
calm
he's a very stern and strong critic of
the war a great opponent of mine we've
had quite a quarrel about it he's a
great sign a writer about science and
other matters
it's a simple matter show this is
politicized hack work of the worst kinds
of statistics in that in that case have
been conclusively and absolutely shown
to be false and I invite anyone to check
it everything I say everything I say has
at least 10 pages of documentation which
I'm willing to share behind it and you
will have your chance to challenge me
and ask questions to Amy now I believe
that that's really all I particularly
need to say except no clap that fast
that's cruel that's mean except to say
this about the question of who's who in
this war
Iraqis not being occupied by Preston
Charney present Salamone was born there
he's had to move a few times he's seen
his villages destroyed and his home
bombed and his family shot at and
murdered so he's not occupying Iran
president Talabani is in fact a leader
of the Patriotic Union of Kurdistan
which is the corresponding member
organisation of the socialist
international it is the Iraqi member
party of the socialist international the
Iraqi Communist Party party with
great record of bad politics but good
civil struggle in Iraq and with great
organization among the women and trade
unionists and journalists and workers of
the country has of course being a member
already of the provisional government in
his campaigning enthusiastically in the
elections there probably some people
among you here who fancy yourself as
having leftist revolutionary credentials
in fact I can tell that you do from the
zoom noises you make and the scars you
can demonstrate from your long
underground Twilight Struggle against
Dick Cheney but while you're
masturbating in that manner
the Iraqi secular left the socialist and
communist movements the workers movement
the trade unions are fighting for their
lives against the most vicious and
indiscriminate form of fascist violence
in any country in the region has seen
for a very long time and the full intent
of that the full intent of that was and
I'll say yes yes in Fallujah was to
establish a Taliban regime and and and a
safe house for al-qaeda revision that's
what we were facing you think you could
fight that without casualties you're
irresponsible
you're a historical we take on this side
of the house without conditions we take
our side with the struggle of the Iraqi
democratic and secular left against
fascism we make no apology those who
have betrayed their own party mr.
Galloway had to be expelled from the
great labor movement of which I myself
still remember because of advocating the
shooting publicly advocating jihad
against British troops now turns on the
Iraqi left who wishes them well as they
as wishes and argues and hopes for their
defeat by an onslaught which would make
Afghanistan seem like a civilised
country what two positions can one take
about this I invite you to consider
ladies and gentlemen and can consider
carefully and thank you
I wanted to see if we could get some
wind screens on the microphones here but
failing that if you could just lower
your microphone mr. Galloway so that you
don't speak right into it great
ten minutes George Galloway grazed
fabrications Johns Hopkins University
and The Lancet the Journal of the
British Medical Association are engaged
in crazed fabrications politicize
fabrication but no crazed fabrications
you said isn't crazed
is there anybody really in this hall who
believes that johns we don't know what
you're supposed to believe that you
think that the academics from one of the
world's finest universities in your own
country are crazed fabricators do you
think that The Lancet the Journal of the
British Medical Association are crazed
fabricators I mean how far I mean how
far how far how far has this neocon rot
seeped into your souls no I'm going to
have to deal with this hypocrite
Hitchens he talks about the death of
soldiers in an occupation army at the
hands of those resisting them he
supported the algerian resistance in its
battle against french occupation which
cost a million lives and he supported
the FLN who conducted the most bitter
unremitting unrelenting military
struggle which would today be described
and was then by the French described as
terrorist and when I met Ben Bella the
leader of the Algerian revolution
was asked why he was placing bombs in
baby carriages and leaving them in the
soup to explode amongst the French
forces and their collaborators he
answered if the French will give us some
of their helicopters some of their
aeroplanes we will give them our baby
carriages isn't that the same situation
today that mr. hitchens friends are the
ones with all the tomahawks all the
Apaches isn't it odd that they should
choose as the names of their weapons the
totems of the Native American population
that they were mercilessly massacred in
centuries one by the Iraqi people have
only themselves with which to fight this
foreign occupation this hypocrite crying
tears for the American army in Iraq
supported the struggle of the Vietnamese
people from the first to the last
as they killed 58,000 American soldiers
in Vietnam he opposed the American war
in Vietnam and supported those fighting
against it today he supports the
American occupation of Iraq and seeks to
slander those fighting against it now
there are al-qaeda elements in Iraq
whose fault is that who brought them
there how did they end up in Iraq there
were no al-qaeda in Iraq before bush and
Blair attacked it and know every
Islamist
in the world is either on his way or
dreaming of being on his way
descending like spores of anthrax on the
gaping wounds in Iraq created by your
war and I'll tell you what they'll then
spill around the world spreading their
jihad exactly as his new or rather old
friends in Afghanistan did the Arab
Afghans who were sent by the American
administration to Afghanistan in the
1980s became al-qaeda in the 1990s and
into the 21st century
so mr. Hitchens policy has succeeded in
making 10,000 new bin Laden's he and his
brother have deeper didn't mean to do it
have deepened the swamp really did not
hatred out of which these Islamist
fundamentalists are claiming you see
well somebody loves you may think that
those aeroplanes in this city on 9/11
came out of a clear blue sky I believe
they emerged out of a swamp of hatred
created by us I believe
I believe I believe I believe that by I
believe I believe I believe please
please please I believe that by their
unending bottomless and total support
for general Sharon's crimes against the
Palestinian the United States I don't
think I don't think you're I don't think
your new friends are quite as keen on
the Palestinians as you once were
Christopher I believe I believe that by
propping up by propping up the puppet
presidents and the corrupt Kings who
ruled the Muslim world almost without
exception from one end to the other
Western policy has created this swamp
hatred against us
it won't matter how many fly swats we
invest in how many Patriot Act's we pass
how many anti-terrorist measures we pass
if you live beside a swamp no amount of
fly swats will protect you from the
monsters who will come out of that swamp
we have to drain that swamp by stopping
that support for Sharon's Israel his
apartheid wall his crimes against the
not not many supporters of the
Palestinians in your ranks tonight mr.
Hitchens I think unless we stop propping
up these dictators in the Muslim world
none of whom would last five minutes if
it were not for the military political
and financial support of countries like
yours and mine unless we stop invading
and occupying Arab and Muslim countries
then we will be forced to endure the
atrocities that took place in New York
on 9/11 and in London on 7-7 over and
over again so if I can't reach your
heart let me at least reach your head in
your own interest
try the war America's own interests
reverse your policy towards Israel and
Palestine reverse your policy towards
dictators in the Muslim world
reverse your policy towards war and
occupation and we can all be safer
christopher hitchens five minutes oh I
had no idea that was the appeal to the
cerebellum that last bit was it well
okay you'll forgive me for pausing I was
waiting for the next shoe to drop
now I began to find myself a little
overwhelmed by mr. Galloway his
compliments I did well he keeps coming
up with them from it's true he did once
say of me that I was the various living
English man of letters and polemicist
and I was grateful I could have wished
it wasn't published in a newspaper
nostalgic for the rule of Brezhnev but
you take your compliments where you can
and I might add that if anything ignited
the hatred and violence that has so come
to preoccupy us in the Muslim world I
think the invasion by the Soviet Union
of the entire territory of Afghanistan
it's virtual annexation as a country and
the certifiable and provable massacre of
many tens of thousands of Afghans as
well as the insult to their religion is
probably a better candidate than the
holding of a free election in Iraq as a
provocation but you see there will
always be bloody fools you think yes of
course now you look at the situation in
Gaza it makes perfect sense to
commandeer a plane load of civilians and
smash it into a building full of
civilians why hadn't I thought of that
before I think you may have noticed mr.
Galloway you picked the wrong City to
say that in
and arguably and arguably the wrong
month as well because some of us are
still mourning some of us are still
mourning please please some of us are
still mourning a mother among other
things the the the very large number the
very large number the very large number
of Americans of all faiths including
very many Arabs and Muslims who were
killed in that disgusting atrocity and
when you say if we don't mend our ways
this will happen to us again if you
weren't an ally of Saddam Hussein and
and Bashar al-assad who had not been an
ally of the preachers of the preachers
of hatred and subversion in the region
how dare you say the United States
supports the Assad regime in Syria you
you say that you that I have no brief
for the Bush administration in this but
it seems to me bizarre that someone
should say fresh from the podium with
Bashar Assad the United States supports
all the dictators in the region what is
this we have in concert for once I must
say with the French succeeded in gaining
some part of the recovery of the
autonomy of Lebanon which was under
under of most corrupt and brutal and
illegal Syrian occupation and the leader
of the Lebanon Socialist Party whose
father was murdered by Assad and the
leader of the Lebanese Communist Party
whose father was murdered last month by
this Assad and all others hailed it as a
liberation and you say it's like the
French taking over Algeria this is
piffle sinister piffle the French claim
in Algeria was that Algeria was part of
France Algeria France says we do not say
Iraq America
Iraq Anglais we judge later liriko say
which it might be if certain numbers of
no I watch I'll block that Network I
came very close there it's also I think
a bit much to be told that these
al-qaida chaps
these killers and sadists and nihilists
and producers of indiscriminate
explosions wouldn't be this way if we
weren't so mean to them now it's true
some of them mr. Sark are we their
leader of kore the bin Laden is leader
there was in Iran before and was well
known to have been in Iraq under the
rule Saddam Hussein I can tell you that
no one gets in out of Iraq at that level
without the president knowing and it's
also true that a group affiliated with
him the Ansar al-islam a fundamentalist
group thought that its main job was to
kill the Kurdish leadership in northern
Iraq the elected leadership was a
strange target I think for a holy war
and it's also true that some of them
came to Iraq after we threw them out of
Afghanistan well that's easy then leave
them in control of Afghanistan don't
mess around with these people don't make
them angry
don't make them mean it's your fault now
this is masochism but it's being offered
to you by say this and someone who
hasn't answered my question in my
challenge I said in round terms when I
opened that this is not just a matter of
which of us can be the rudest because I
already conceded that's mr. Galvin well
which of us can be the most cerebral
because he's already considered that to
me but I said that there's a further
grudge between us which is this I say
that mr. Galloway discussed the
allocation of oil-for-food profits that
stole directly from the Iraqi people and
that helped to corrupt the scheme and
program of the United Nations I say he
discussed that personally with mr. Tareq
Aziz in Baghdad at least once and if he
will put his name to an affidavit that
formally denies that we can have done
with this business but if he does not
it's going to haunt him all over every
stop of this tour and all the way back
to England and everywhere he goes to
raise the flag of jihad in the Middle
East this I promise you I promise you
George Galloway five minutes complete
lie it's a lie like the other lies on
your leaflets that you are handing out
like an idiot on the street before this
meeting it's a lie
buy my book you don't want to buy it go
to the website of respect coalition dot
org and read it I've already dealt with
this it's a lie
nobody ever discussed oil allocations
with me not Tariq Aziz not any I've
already said it under oath never mind an
affidavit under oath on pain of
imprisonment in front of the US Senate
where that smokescreen will not wash you
want me to run through the dictatorships
you're supporting do you want me to
Roger yes I know that is masochism that
really is masochism Saudi Arabia the
prison state told me to run through the
family business more Colleoni than
Sainsbury's that runs Kuwait do you want
me to run through the dictatorship in
Egypt he has the gall to claim the
election in Egypt as a fruit of the
massacre of hundreds of thousands of
people in Iraq Hosni Mubarak got more
votes in the so-called free election
last week than he got in the election he
admitted he raped six years previously
and you want to call that democracy you
talk about democracy in Lebanon your
Cedar Revolution
it wasn't democracy they were demanding
in the square of the Cedar Revolution if
there was democracy in Lebanon Sheikh
nasrallah the leader of Hezbollah would
be the president of Lebanon but he can't
be very interesting it can't be the
president of Lebanon no Muslim can be
the president of Lebanon you've got to
be a Christian to be the president of
even though only 20% of the population
of Lebanon are Christians and how did
that come about because the United
States Marines waded ashore in Beirut in
1958 to impose that Constitution on the
people of Lebanon you have the goal to
talk about dictatorship and democracy
mr. Hitchens
your and you have the goal to talk about
corruption in the Middle East your
president and his father are complicit
to the tune of millions and millions of
pounds in the corruption of the Arabian
Gulf in Saudi Arabia with the Carlyle
Group with secret Saudi investment in
the failed business enterprises of
george w bush and you a former
Trotskyist wrote in the newspapers that
you are backing the re-election of
George W Bush Dick Cheney Donald
Rumsfeld and the rest of this gang you
should be ashamed of yourself but you're
not
but but you're not ashamed of yourself
at all it's true I praised you you were
a butterfly you know a slug
you did right like an angel but you're
no working for the devil and damn you
and all your works
well that concludes the first
part of this debate now it'll be a
little more freewheeling I asked you I
asked you not to speak over each other
but you can go back and forth more I'd
like you each to think of a question
you'd like to ask the other but I'd like
to start by asking Christopher Hitchens
you began today by talking about the
evils of Saddam Hussein that though was
not the main argument of President Bush
and invading Iraq it was weapons of mass
destruction and links to al-qaeda would
you say that he engaged in systematic
campaign to deceive the American people
and the world
it's your first point you see it used to
be said I will Bush any in the first
Gulf or Bush Senior he only cared about
the removal of Saddam Hussein from
Kuwait hidden care about the Iraqi
people or the Kurds he only pretended to
and the UN resolutions only allowed him
to do Kuwait and fair enough but so
whatever you do you're going to be
accused of not giving out your full
agenda so I don't feel myself
particularly rung by that point in his
address to United Nations in fact the
first address on the subject the
president did mention a full menu as you
might say of indictment against Iraq
which included or I should say a row of
the Baathist dictatorship which included
its record of genocide it's proven
record of deception about weapons of
mass destruction it's links with
terrorism and his violation of all the
UN resolutions governing these things I
have written that I think both Mr Blair
and mr. Bush insulted not just their own
electorates but everyone in the world by
preferring to shall we say frightened
people preferring to frighten dementia
educate or enlighten them and I have
written that repeatedly I believe it
very much I think a good course has been
gravely disfigured by that by those
political deformities but if you will
let allow me to say so II mean just as I
am NOT personally responsible for
creating 100,000 al-qaeda fighters nor
am I here as someone who can answer
questions on behalf of the Bush
administration rather to the contrary
the it's it's it's a a single issue
question with me I think that the
president was right to do what the
previous president and vice president
mr. Clinton and mr. Gore had only
promised to do and what the United
States Senate had only voted to do which
was to move Iraq into the post Saddam
Hussein era well all that was decided
and repeatedly promised by the preceding
administration and by the US Senate when
George Bush was still a provincial
governor of Texas so I don't think this
is a subject that can be changed just by
saying Dick Cheney and knowing that
there are enough morons there will
always be when you say that
now I'm but you see I'm a bit of a comma
Churchill armed in the last moments or
so I'm not certain that the plain
meaning of words as uttered by me is
being understood by the audience because
if they understood me to say that I
favored the royal family of Saudi Arabia
Cheney point I apologize I'm sure I
didn't say that and don't think anything
I said could be construed to mean it
when I said I supported SIA dad Dean
Ibrahim the moral leader of the Egyptian
opposition who was in Mubarak's jail I
don't believe I gave an endorsement of
mr. Mubarak mr. Galloway appears to
think that anything will do here and
beneath each gutter there's another
gutter gurgling away underneath but I
would rather to debate this question on
its so to say merits and demerits now
just on this point of weaponry um
if you have as you do have in the case
of Saddam Hussein's Iraq a regime that
has used chemical and biological weapons
against some of its own inhabitants in
costar against Iran several times that
hasn't had run an elaborate method of
concealment that offered mr. Tareq Aziz
mr. Galloway's best friend I think he
told the Senate for a Senate
subcommittee and he said best friend or
very close friend man he's met 12 times
spent Christmas with mr. cherrick Aziz
has offered when I have an affidavit on
this and we will get one from mr.
Galloway to have put the two together
the UN chief inspector for Iraq was
offered two million dollars in internal
Ghazis off his face to face to change
his inspections we knew that we knew
that dummy sites will run up for you and
fools to inspect and we know that
material was buried and moved and we
know that scientists were terrorized and
told their families would be lavishly
killed if they cooperated with an
inspection on this knowledge of which
I'm sorry to say I am the prisoner I
cannot not know this any more than I
could not know that Saddam was trying to
buy weapons off the shelf from North
Korea
on the basis of this establish of all
provable knowledge who is going to say
well let's give Saddam Hussein the
benefit of the doubt if he says he's not
fooling around with weapons now what
responsible leader of any democracy
could face his people later if that bet
turned out to be wrong and say well I
had every reason to think he was on the
level
on get real be serious on this and your
response to : powell saying that his UN
speech was sustained his record your
response to Colin Powell saying that his
UN speech making the case of weapons of
mass destruction was a stain on his
record just a minute response
I don't give a damn what Colin Pell
thinks about anything I never have and I
never will I think I've noticed that
he's having been for a long time the
most overrated probably favored the
United States he's running for the
nomination to over most overrated man in
the world but I don't really care and
you don't make me George Galloway Saddam
Hussein currently sits in jail do you
think he has committed any crimes and if
so what Saddam Hussein committed real
and serious crimes against the people of
Iraq most of them in the 1980s when he
was the closest friend of the United
States and Great Britain
he he invaded Iran at the behest of the
United States and Britain in a war which
killed a million people on either side a
war in which chemical and biological
weapons were used by both sides sold to
both sides by countries like Britain
America and West Germany he he killed
massacred Kurdish people in Halabja I
was one of those who demonstrated
against it mister Tony Blair nor any of
his cabinet participated in any of those
demonstrations because then the Baathist
regime in Iraq against whom I was
resolutely and actively involved were
the best friends and customers of the
then allies United States and the United
Kingdom
Saddam created a killing field in Iraq
like all dictatorships he one of the go
billion tricks the Hitchens has
performed this evening with his little
leaflet is to try to give you the
impression that in my book I'm not the
only one I come out in favor of Saddam
Hussein and in fact I denounce him in
the most withering terms but you
wouldn't get that from the leaflet that
Hitchens has given out this evening so
not only do I think that Saddam Hussein
committed real and serious crimes
against the Iraqi people I said so at
the time he was committing them I was
denounced for saying so at the time he
was committing them as a communist
troublemaker disrupting the profitable
relations between Iraq and better
um Amy I know where Spencer hated in
order but I think I think you would
think ladies and gentlemen if I had no
reply to that to you they see what mr.
Galloway claims that at a certain period
in the 1980s he was supporting Iraqi
Democrats and protesting against Saddam
Hussein knowing what he was capable of
knowing what he had done knowing the
genocide for example committed in in
Kurdistan and knowing of the aggressions
and the chemical weaponry that had been
deployed in Ronnie says he knows that
I've had the opportunity to check with
the woman and Chloe and this very
distinguished member of the Labour left
in the British Parliament who was the
chairman of the relevant organisation
the campaign for the restoration of
democratic rights in Iraq she says she
has no memory of mr. Galloway's
participation but let's say that we take
his word for it it means that when he
went
having said that he thought that Kuwait
was part of the Iraqi motherland to
greet Saddam Hussein in 1994 in Iraq and
to salute him for his courage and
ability he went and and to take his side
again it meant that he went in foot on
his own evidence he went in full
knowledge of the fact that he was
dealing with a murderer and a monster
and a dictator so the the pit of
exculpation that you attempt to dig mr.
Galloway has just swallowed you up and
the record will show it yes but
but but you opposed the war in 1991 in
the full knowledge of what had happened
that Halabja just three years before
you're the one who went on television
denouncing President Bush for his plan
to invade and destroy the regime of
Saddam Hussein you are the one who did I
saw you with my own eyes yes moving I
was there too I saw the words tumble out
yeah yeah keep your wig on you told
heston name four countries around the
country of Iraq that you're so keen to
attack you were in completely full
knowledge even better knowledge because
it was even fresher in 1991 the nature
of the Saddam regime but you were
against the invasion of Iraq in 1991
presumably because you calculated the
attend dictatorship in one country in
the Arab world was one thing unleashing
the right of big superpowers to invade
and occupy other people's countries
without legal authority without judicial
permission of the authorities political
and legal in the world was an even
bigger danger even bigger danger I was
uh I was a small fry in 1991 nobody in
America was watching me on television as
I was watching you on television in
America and cheering you for your for
sightedness for your wisdom for your
subtlety in knowing doesn't get it yes
sometimes in life you have to choose
between bad and bad or sometimes in life
you have to choose between evil and more
evil that's what you did in 1991 the
only difference between us is that on
the road somewhere Damascus I would say
I don't know where you
careful I don't know what it was well
there was vanity fair' or whether it was
the lucrative contracts that you've
landed since but somehow you decided in
2003 maybe it was the whiskey maybe it
was the whiskey
somehow you decided in 2003 to take a
line that was the complete opposite of
the line you used to take now you want
us to gloss over that point you say well
yes you did you said I can't understand
was devoted to this point
were you lying then in 91 or are you
lying now were you wrong in 91 or are
you wrong now if you were wrong in 91
how should we believe you're right now
in 2005 if you're capable of such
drastic dramatic erratic swings from
being in favour of a devastating war to
be against a devastating war to be in
favor of the liberation struggle in
Algeria and Vietnam and Ireland but
against the liberation struggle now in
Palestine and Iraq if your liberation
struggle
almost if I can use the word that you
used ll crazed shifts of opinion how can
anybody take you seriously
ooh I got a question image again I am
itching again I worry about the plain
meaning of words I believe I said
earlier that I held a different view of
the time and has since changed it my
articles and statements against the war
my reports from Iraq and its neighbors
at the time are all available in a in a
book published by their so it's called
um this one is called for the sake of
argument and I haven't repudiated them
it's there no longer hold to them
I was unpersuaded in the following
manner I was persuaded I don't have the
education to work that one out
I was unpersuaded in the following
manner I ended the war I ended the war
in northern Iraq where I saw what the
real consequences of Saddam Hussein's
rule had been I knew something about it
there's no question but I wasn't
prepared to be told by so many people
that in their view the American
intervention had saved their lives than
the lives of their families and I I
hadn't got a clever anti-war argument to
make to that point and I began a process
of reexamination of which I can't really
say or be expected to say that I'm
ashamed your writer had some fun at the
expense of Charlton Heston I mean I can
remember it too when I asked him what
the neighboring countries were he said
Bahrain which is of course an island and
it was all good sport and I'm not
ashamed of any of that either but there
comes a point when you've got to be a
little more serious now the fact is
there was no invasion by George Bush of
Iraq nor was there any UN mandate to do
so I'm talking about 99 why wasn't an
invasion of Iraq it was an expulsion of
Iraq from Kuwait by a coalition which
included even Syria now if mr. Assad can
change his mind on this and I can and
many other people too I suppose we have
to congratulate you on being absolutely
a hundred percent consistent in your
support for unmentionable thugs and
criminals
what about the issue of a timetable
withdrawing from Iraq or withdrawing
immediately or not withdrawing let me
first put the question to George
Galloway what do you think needs to
happen today mr. Hitchens says that you
have no intention of Iraq Americana well
it looks like a duck walks like a duck
and quacks like a duck the chances are
it probably is a duck and down on the
ground in Iraq it doesn't look much like
the United States is planning to leave
of their own volition after all they're
building massive and what they hope to
be permanent military bases to stationed
their forces there they have engineered
a puppet regime which they intend to
allow to be a kind of lipstick on the
ugly face of their occupation which will
allow their corporate friends do I
really need to mention them do I need to
name them do I really need to mean
they've probably got supporters in the
hall might as well
Christopher's new best friends best tell
and Halliburton and all these robber
barons these vulture capitalists who are
cutting Iraq like a shawarma stealing
the American people's money stealing the
Iraqi people's money you think they are
planning on going home anytime soon of
their own volition think Halliburton
intends to leave do you think there are
plans to force the privatization of all
of Iraq's industries and services
because they intend to allow Iraq to be
free do you think they're forcing of
Iraqi farmers to buy patented seeds so
that they'll be forever in debt to the
agribusiness companies of the United
States is because they ever allow intend
to allow Iraq to be free they intend if
they can to have an Iraq Emira
Kanha but the Iraqis have decided
otherwise and that's what you can't
stand that's what you can't stand you
see you slander the Iraqi resistance as
being foreign fight I have to laugh at
this term foreign fighters yeah which
part of Iraq is general Myers from which
parts of Iraq are the British and
American generals from the most foreign
fighters in Iraq are wearing British and
American uniforms in Iraq but the idea
the idea that the Iraqi resistance of
foreigners or Islamist fundamentalists
is denied now even by the testimony of
the United States generals themselves
Hitchens is clinging to an argument
which has even been abandoned by the
United States generals themselves only
six percent according to the United
States government of prisoners taken
from amongst the Iraqi resistance have
been foreigners if Arabs from
neighbouring Arab countries can be
called foreigners by a government in the
United States of America that means that
94% of them are Iraqis now you should
know better you see we were told in
Vietnam that if if only the right
Chinese and the Soviet Union would stop
meddling in Vietnam there would be no
Vietnamese resistance they couldn't bear
to concede that the Vietnamese people
were prepared to fight them with their
teeth if necessary to rid their country
a foreign domination they told us
in every single anti-colonial struggle
that it was foreign interference
it was the Reds or it's the Islamists
from outside if only we could extricate
them kapow the man in a turban with a
beard in the Tora Bora or his lieutenant
Azhar Cowie
who it turns out actually fell out with
bin Laden a very long time ago according
to the excellent rebuttal
of mr. Hitchens ten points by a
professor one call a Michigan University
available on the internet yes to anyone
who wants to read a man even more
cerebral than Christopher Hitchens this
slander of the Iraqi resistance is
self-deluding you're fooling yourselves
if you believe it because if you believe
it you must believe that if only you
could seal the borders a bit more funny
you could get rid of the foreign
fighters then everything would be rosy
everything would be hunky-dory this is a
level of self delusion which borders
frankly on the racist the vast majority
of the people of Iraq are against the
American and British occupation of their
country your own friend Coburn writing
from Iraq recently said so the vast
majority of Iraqis want this occupation
to end Turan the vast majority of those
fighting to bring it to an end our
Iraqis get used to it
get over understanding or you're fooling
yourselves
George Galloway with one word do you
think the US and British forces should
be withdrawn immediately not only do I
Christopher Hitchens when do you think
the US troops should leave Iraq I think
I can be as precise there perhaps not as
terse as mr. Galloway on this point and
I should thank him by the way for
eliciting or allowing allowing me to
elicit or you perhaps there's a general
to elicit from him what I feared didn't
hope in other words a full declaration
of support for the campaign of sabotage
and murder and beheading that has taken
the lives of brave journalists
demolished demolish the offices
demolish the offices demolish the
offices of the United Nations shut down
senior clerics outside their places of
worship and continues as a campaign of
mayhem to this day you will not think
you've fallen out of the night you've
fallen out of the gutter into the sewer
you might all care to remember that you
are being televised
ladies and gentlemen I trust your
mother's and not watching your shouting
at me down so I can answer the question
you unclear on the concept
but I will proceed if I'm allowed to but
I'm just reminding you you're on telly
ok just hope your friends and relatives
aren't watching now this a campaign a
campaign a campaign of mayhem and
sabotage that was most obviously
directed here's where what it moved to
my point in February last against the
only attempt that Iraq has ever seen to
hold a national election to provide a
parliament a constitution and an elected
government now what are the odds do you
think that those who are blowing up the
offices of the UN and who recently shot
down as senior Sunni cleric in Baghdad
because he too wants an end to the
occupation but he asked his congregation
to vote in the upcoming elections what
are the odds that these people represent
the secret silent majority in Iraq as
say the FLN did in Algeria well that's
just do some simple relatively simple
arithmetic in the three Kurdish
provinces of Iraq there is really not a
single sympathizer either of the Baath
Party of al-qaeda it can be taken as a
certainty that's we know at least 20% of
the population consider this resistance
to be a fascist pest and have committed
their heroic Armed Forces because there
is a rebel army in Iraq there is a
People's Army there is a guerrilla force
in rock it's called the Peshmerga it's
the people's the People's Liberation
Army of Kurdistan and it fights on our
side and we at last because mr. Galloway
is right that our policy in the past has
been heinous we at last fight on their
side - excellent now very well moving
right along
it is admitted I don't think it's even
denied by the egregious a figure of a
professor Cole who's never set foot in
the region though claims to speak Farsi
and various other languages I don't
believe it's denied even by him and he
changes his mind on these things about
once a week that Ayatollah Sistani Grand
Ayatollah Sistani is considered by the
majority of the iraqi shiaa to be this
let's say at least their spiritual
leader if it would be not to Grand
Ayatollah Sistani and if you like if it
had been up to my advice to mr. Paul
Bremer would have had to call elections
much earlier than he did and so he
should have done and make a transfer of
sovereign
much sooner than he did and so he should
have done but we have no reason to doubt
that the forces that favor this
transition to a federal democratic
system in Iraq where no one group rules
by violence or terror or by dictatorship
where there is federal and local
autonomy and where disputes are not
settled by us is favored by the latent
majority of the Iraqi people because if
that's not so it's very easy for them to
participate in the version and what they
do instead is they try and sabotage it I
think that's a very eloquent campaign
that's being run by mr. Galloway's
heroic resistance now to stop these
elections from happening to speak to the
people the terrified people have been
through three and a half decades of war
and fascism and terror and never give
them a moment to breathe never give them
a moment's freedom from fear and
intimidation shame on the people shame
on the people who call this a liberation
christopher hitchens what about the
costs of this war at home I've just come
from New Orleans across the political
spectrum you're hearing more and more
dissent and criticism of what's
happening in Iraq because of what didn't
happen in New Orleans the lack of
National Guard in Mississippi and
Louisiana the weapons rather the
vehicles that were needed that weren't
there
so two questions on that what about the
cost here at home with the Hurricane
Katrina and the lack of response and if
the we see clearly because the reporters
are uninvent in New Orleans and they
really presented the pictures if we see
clearly the way the u.s. responded here
in terms of rebuilding or not what makes
you think the u.s. is any better in Iraq
I would caution people from adopting a
zero-sum mentality in this respect I had
the opportunity to speed with a close
associate of Lieutenant General Steve
Brown some time ago said that he had
before the situation became as dire as
it did had been able to call up the
Secretary of Defense and say I have
200,000 troops you can have any time but
the question is where's the order going
to come from the president can't as you
know ami cannot order American troops
into action in the State of the Union he
has to be asked by the governor for this
to happen and the governor has to admit
well I'm sorry it's in the constant I'm
sorry it's in the Constitution
it is in the unless you Iraq unless you
want unless you want to invoke the
insurrection Act which hasn't been I
think invoked and since the Civil War so
the the fact of the matter is there were
more than enough soldiers they just
weren't given the orders in time and
that's a matter few but as soon as they
made their appearance didn't everything
start to look a lot better aren't you
proud of general Honore are you not
proud that that a man born into that a
man born into segregation and
discrimination is leading really hard
professional tough generous brave men
and women in uniform for the recovery of
new orleans and all the time has a son
in Fallujah and seems to think he can
manage both I think it's hugely to the
credit of the United States Armed Forces
that they would consider it ignoble to
abandon their commitments in Sadr City
and in Halabja and elsewhere ignoble and
parochial and provincial now mr.
Galloway came a little near the knuckle
a moment ago and decided to overlook it
he said what I said was bordering on
racist I really feel I'm entitled to ask
him to withdraw that imputation I think
that's an appropriate thing to say but I
will have to add that for people to
start pumping out propaganda before the
bodies had even been uncovered in New
Orleans saying and to make points
demagogic often saying they wouldn't be
dead if they weren't black about people
haven't been identified yet whose
parents don't know where they are and to
say this wouldn't have happened if we
weren't wasting money on Arabs that that
is an appeal to the most base provincial
isolationist and chauvinist mentality
I'm so glad mr. Hitchens gave that and
so you see this is where it ends isn't
it
you start off being the liberal
mouthpiece of one of the most
reactionary governments this country has
ever seen
on the subject of war you see you've got
your own liberal reasons for doing so
and you end up an apologist and a
mouthpiece for those miserable
malevolent incompetence who couldn't
even pick up the bodies of their own
citizens in New Orleans in the aftermath
of a hurricane
that's where it ends Hitchens that's
where it ends you end up you end up a
mouthpiece and an apologist for the Bush
family who is matriarch you want to talk
about racism
what about Barbara Bush
what about Barbara Bush who took a look
at the poor huddled masses in the
Astrodome and told us they'd never had
it so good who told us they were better
off than they'd ever been
underprivileged people now in an
Astrodome the only problem with whom she
said was that so many of them wanted to
ski in Texas you know Hitchens you're a
court jester you're a court jester
not not at Camelot like other ridiculous
former liberals before you but the Court
of the Bourbon bushes Barbara Bush the
Marie Antoinette of modern-day American
politics
well I think I have to say a quick word
ma if I maybe this is all good not about
stuff but I must say mrs. Bush senior
does remind me of I think it was Lady
Diana Cooper who was once stopped
outside them Claridge's Hotel in London
as she was waiting under the umbrella
for the day Mila to be brought round
after a ball ragged man approached her
and said ma'am he sort of haven't eaten
for three days she said we were very
foolish then he was trying if necessary
he was forced yourself if necessary
it's called a tumbrel remark in some
circles um yes I don't know where the
Marie Antoinette a cake shop was in the
Astrodome but I feel noticed I don't I
didn't say that I defended the
president's record on this and I've
written very critically about it already
for all of you to read in Slate Magazine
what I did what I will not have said
what I will not have said is that we
should go to a refugee woman in Biloxi
and say to her do you realize the a
Rabb's have stolen the money that should
have come to you and we have note we
have no right to put the poor against
each other in that way it's and to
betray our internationalism that we have
no right whatever to to insult to insult
the tremendous performance of the United
States Armed Forces once they're put
into action and I will add one more
thing the 82nd airborne in the first Air
Cavalry so far from our being distracted
by Iraq have learned in Iraq matters of
civil reconstruction water distribution
purification crunch over that have been
extremely useful to them in New Orleans
the case the case don't G I would advise
you not to jeer these men and women
while you're being televised ladies and
gentlemen I would advise you not to do
it the shame is yours I'm awfully sorry
I meant to have said that before in
anything yes and we will bring Sadr City
back to and we will rebuild him objects
we will and not only that the Army Corps
of Engineers the Army Corps of Engineers
has just finished building a new
extension of the Kabul to Kandahar
Highway in Afghanistan that's what the
Army Corps of Engineers did which means
that the journeys between several major
cities in Afghanistan which used to take
days over rocky and dangerous roads
are now much easier and a triumph of
humanism has occurred if I was the last
patient person I would get the
impression that someone was trying to
shut me up here don't even think about
it what I say what I say doesn't require
your endorsement and isn't drowned by
your zoo noises because I'm on c-span
now and all they can hear is you paying
they can make me out alright so just
give it up okay
simmer down or let me put it like this
it takes a bit more than that
it takes a bit more than that tough guys
and gals just shot me up as well now you
might the word warlord is quite often
used when we discuss Afghanistan which
the country would haven't talked about
enough
whereas I say the Taliban would still be
in power if the anti-war movements
advice had been heeded what is a warlord
award is someone who can control a piece
of road by force who can with a few
brigands roll a rock into that road and
say you don't pass without paying
tribute to me now warlordism is one of
the seed beds of the swamp that mr.
Galloway describes that breathes
terrorism if you can build solid wide
roads that directly connect the cities
you abolish brigandage and watery are
you in favor of abandoning Afghanistan
to wall or wall origin brigand area ghin
and see what happens I do I heard a few
yeses I thought I might maybe consider
carefully what you may be demanding I
think it is a most excellent use of our
Army Corps of Engineers to help liberate
Afghanistan and its neighbors from that
kind of charity I also think perhaps it
would be ignoble to add this it is not
without a dimension that involves our
own self-interest because we do indeed
know the swamp from which the enemy
first came and this is what it means to
drain it that and swatting the
mosquitoes I'll have to a hat killing
them in other words poisoning them
putting them down
knowing an enemy when we see one
treating an enemy like an enemy
recognizing that we have a deadly foe
not surrendering not surrendering at the
invitation of a courtier of sadists I'm
not a member of the bush entourage ha
I've never appeared on a public platform
with a dictator I never have and I never
will I couldn't face you if I had that
on my record it must be some sordid kind
of displaced guilt that makes mr.
Galloway want to throw out accusations
like this I've never done that and to
come fresh from embracing these
blood-stained bastards and to say to you
it's your fault that these people aren't
Caesars more than we should be expected
to take before before you each give your
closing five minutes I wanted to ask
each of you Christopher Hitchens
and then I'll ask you a question about
the media George Galloway but
Christopher Hitchens as you've changed
your views over time do you feel that
the media is friendlier to you I'm just
trying to think I was a columnist for
say Vanity Fair which is what I think
where most of my readers follow my stuff
before I resigned from the nation for
example and I still it doesn't well get
that job by quitting the nation I have a
feeling I know the imputation of what
you're saying but I think I probably
wouldn't be the best judge in my own
cause I can see the editor of the Nation
magazine sitting in the front row I feel
fairly confident that if you asked him
he would not say that I left the nation
in order to improve my salary prospects
but and I frankly think that's a bit of
a waste of a question but if
lately mainly if the impression I give
is of someone who is a mercenary and
actually a bad at handling money as that
it's an impression I wouldn't be able to
correct by denying it that was a cup of
whiskey man sir well I don't know about
you ma but I'm beginning to think this
debate is running out of steam a little
yes I have the same impression if if mr.
Hitchens agrees that might be that we
should begin to think about winding it
up without further ado I see some of the
audience are leaving the hour is late
and I think we've generated about as
much light as we're going to and as much
heat as we ought to mr. Hitchens is
right I'm certainly no pacifist and
neither is he and we probably oughtn't
to get any more belligerent towards each
other than we have don't worry about
that all right why don't we give why
don't he give me if I still have the mic
I would just like to say that this issue
of what are the Iraq war was necessary
and just or not is one which is already
being adjudicated upon by the people who
are watching c-span by the people who
read these proceedings this evening in
their opinion polls in their comments of
all kinds there are very very few
friends left of the argument that mr.
Hitchens has put of course on the far
shores of the crazed right-wing neocon
circles in the United States he's a new
hero but amongst the mainstream majority
and amongst those with whom mr. Hitchens
used to travel this subject is already
adjudged you see
the Elysian Fields that he seeks to
conjure up in his depiction of Iraq
today simply don't bear any resemblance
to the situation we all see on our
television screens and read about in our
newspapers every day The Situation's not
getting better in Iraq it's getting
worse religious fundamentalism to which
he is so opposed has been put in power
in Iraq by the invasion of bush and
Blair the the Grand Ayatollah Ali
al-sistani of whom mr. Hitchens now it's
very bizarre a Trotskyist friend of the
Grand Ayatollah Ali al-sistani that he
speaks so approvingly of now is the
ruling power in Iraq and believe me he
is an Islamic fundamentalist believe me
he wants to ensure that the people who
live under his purview follow every dot
and , of the Islamic fundamentalist
agenda and I warn you to be careful of
what you wish for because if either of
the United States or its friend Israel
attacks Iran in the next period over the
issue of nuclear power Iran will answer
in Iraq and they will answer above all
in the south of Iraq we are the Grand
Ayatollah Ali al-sistani is top dog
thanks to your friends bush and Blair
extremism has not been dampened down by
this war it has been fantastically
enhanced the number of people who hate
us in the world has not been reduced but
has been greatly enlarged the confidence
of people in their own governments and
their own political systems
the belligerent countries has not been
enhanced it has been substantially
undermined the ability of the
international legal and political system
to operate as a means of resolving
disputes has not been enhanced by this
affair but has been fatally undermined
by it this is a disaster this war on
Iraq when the French statesman tell Iran
was told by an aide of the mother of a
political opponent the aide said it's a
terrible crime sir and tell Iran
answered it's worse than a crime it's a
blunder this attack on Iraq and its
subsequent occupation is a crime yes but
it's worse than a crime it's a blunder
it's a blunder that's made us all more
insecure it's a blunder which is
destabilized the world multiplied our
enemies it has few friends left and you
will regard yourselves as having been
privileged in years to come
that you were able to witness the
ridiculous spectacle of this popinjay
who continues to support
christopher hitchens the final five
minutes well I do share mr. Yahweh's
feeling that the the debate or exchange
may have passed the point of being point
four I can't object to being called a
popinjay since the principal definition
is that of a target for archery and shot
which I daresay I've brought upon myself
and certainly feel of weather and in mr.
Calloway's case I'll just have to say
since even from the chair there was a
question as it were about my motive in
this then I think I can describe it
fairly simply and it was rather fairly
put in fact by my great antagonist held
myosin the editor of The American
Prospect in a recent article said Mr
Jersey the motivation for being involved
in this appears to be his old friendship
and solidarity with the secular Iraqi
Kurdish left forces well that's nice
because just for once someone has got
right how it was that I made some new
friends didn't lose the old ones unless
they wanted to desert me but I will tell
you that some of the admirers on the
moveon.org world that I may have lost
are well worth it in exchange for the
comrades I have made and once I mr.
Galloway may have enough in his memory
as a socialist the the name that he's
begun to disgrace so gravely so horribly
to remember that if you take a position
of solidarity with your comrades you
take it win or lose up or down you don't
say well I'm sorry comrades brothers and
sisters I'm gonna have to desert you now
because they might say well why is that
and I might say have to tell them well
because Michael Moore said so or because
Cindy says so or because someone's
offered me some oil-for-food money to do
so and I'm not gonna do it
you would be you would have more to be
proud of ladies and gentlemen if you
could after tonight point to something
that you had done to help build up the
new Iraq went to something that you were
doing to help the Iraqi women's
organizations who indeed do have to
combat fundamentalism point to something
you had done to help unearth the mass
graves and consoled the relatives of
those who are found in them point is
something to you could you had
yourselves contributed to the to the
emancipation of Kurdistan you could saw
something perhaps to help the new Iraqi
press and media acquire some more modern
equipment on which to conduct this
debate
why don't you think of the possible
nobility of that alternative because to
offer your solidarity instead to the 154
operations that are sabotaging for this
not process is to be is to be I think
hopelessly covered in shame and
something that you'll look back on with
with real regret so I it's not too late
there are many many many outlets for
your feel for your compassion your
energy your internationalism many Iraqis
are crying out for your help don't
appear do not do not appear do not
appear to be deaf on a point as
important as this and with that that's
the end of my pro bono a bit from now
and if you want to talk to me you need a
receipt and I'll be sitting selling
books because this is after all America
thank you so much for coming
thank you very much for coming out
tonight George Galloway will be signing
copies of mr. Galloway goes to
Washington Christopher Hitchens will be
signing love poverty and war and blood
class and Empire I'll also be signing
the exception to the rulers you can form
three lines here you can get your books
at the back at the Haymarket book table
in the lobby or right here thanks very
much for being with us